comme paul belmondo qu'est-ce qui m'a
lui aussi voit si dany boon quand tout à
des guilis poupe et c'est là nous
il savait
il s'en tenant même logique au rythme de
ce pont qui relie boom à l'oreille
comment ça va ça va pas mal bien on est
votre compagne oui c'est comme ça qu'on
dit c'est comme ça dans c'est comme ça
que j'ai découvert l'émission
voilà ma femme me la fais tout le temps
dont elle est sans arrêt sauf que alors
j'ai dit quand tu veux hein tu reviens
tu est la bienvenue
ça vous embête quand on vous dit que
vous êtes le mari de judith godrèche non
pas du tout ça va ça me plaît quand elle
est venue on lui a demandé si elle vous
beauties et si elle avait pris deux
processions de votre esprit
elle a dit non non de demande de mon
corps est parfois dans mon esprit ça va
quoi vous allez encore libre arbitre ou
pouvez faire tout ce que c'est au début
et premier gain de georges est et gaza
le mieux est des fois ça revient des
fraises en la regardant bien on a
raconté plein de trucs on a raconté que
vous aviez une oreillette pour le
spectacle qu'elle vous parlé dans
l'oreillette
le premier soir à la première est la
toute première j'ai très peur aussi de
deux heures de spectacle c'est très long
à prendre je le savais en fait mais j'ai
très très peur donc j'avais
effectivement une oreillette et judith
me disait tout le texte alors qu'elle
était censée me le dire que quand
j'avais des trous mais elle avait peur
choisi un temps de silence
ses parts a été terrible on cherche une
oreillette on dit tout ce que je dois
vous dire a fixé jeudi au caire
vous êtes rencontrés sur le plateau de
bimboland oui avec ils avaient ordre
il y avait en tout le monde c'est mon
film finalement il a une certaine
importance
c'est vrai oui on en parle tellement
aujourd'hui je pense que vous savez je
suis sur un bimboland il a marché très
fort en allemagne on va parler de le
tout nouveau spectacle le sol et comment
on fait cher dany boon bien bien bien
directement et très disciplinés ce soir
mise en scène par judith godrèche bien
au casino de paris donc alors j'ai eu la
même réaction que jérôme béglé de paris
match
parce que j'ai vu le papier ilim je suis
allé voir dany boon moi je n'avais
jamais vu sur scène un don qu'il y était
allé il savait pas très bien ce que
c'était en fait j'ai vu chez drucker
mais pas si jamais sur scène et il se
demandait si c'est allé lui plaire et
moi aussi
et puis moi ça m'a plu et lui aussi oui
c'est vrai il dit même en poussant la
porte de versailles et je m'emmerde être
un truc et je me suis m'arrête pas
seulement parce que j'avais judith à
côté moi vraiment me suis regardé si je
me marrais elle est très présente avec
des coups de coude non dans les collèges
alors deux ans d'écriture pas d'écriture
depuis les notes dans les bistrots c'est
ça dans des bistrots dans des bistrots
des bières et des notes sur les sons les
dessous de boeck
ouais et puis un jour elle en vacances
au soleil vous classez vos notes et ça
fait un spectacle oui
sympa comme boulot à décrire ces génies
après en plus et payer et tout pour
parce qu'on veut le lien entre tous les
personnages c'est quoi c'est la névrose
je suivrai animateur de tv s'amenant
daniela lumbroso aurait pu dire oui
daniela c'est ça
j'avais mieux en ce moment je fasse
attention au dernier la vie n'est qu'un
jeu pour toi on va regarder à quoi ça
ressemble à un et deux